[Música]
así lo en México es lo que busca el
expresidente peruano Pedro Castillo el
ex mandatario ratificó su solicitud
mientras cumple siete días de prisión
preventiva antes de su juicio por
rebelión el proceso se desató luego de
que él intentará asestar un autogolpe de
estado como lo dijo la fiscalía
Estados Unidos da un paso hacia adelante
en el matrimonio igualitario la ley que
protege federalmente esta Unión salió
Invicta del Congreso con la aprobación
final de la cámara de representantes
este jueves Ahora sólo falta la firma
del presidente Joe biden para blindar
estas uniones
después de dos días de receso en el
mundial de Qatar comienzan los cuartos
de final este viernes argentina se juega
su paso a la semifinal al enfrentarse a
Países Bajos mientras que Brasil se
medirá frente a Croacia detalles desde
duha Bienvenidos a las noticias que
France 24 le dedica a América y al
Mundial de Qatar lo saluda María Clara
calle iniciamos en Perú la justicia
ordenó siete días de prisión preventiva
para el expresidente Pedro Castillo a la
espera de un juicio en el que lo acusan
de rebelión el ex mandatario intentó
disolver el congreso el 7 de diciembre y
refugiarse en la Embajada Mexicana de
Lima pero la policía lo detuvo antes de
llegar aún así el jueves el canciller
mexicano Marcelo ebrard confirmó que
Castillo ratificó la solicitud de asilo
Andrés granadillo nos amplía
Castillo ratifica su solicitud de asilo
a México así lo informó el canciller
mexicano Marcelo ebrard desde su cuenta
de Twitter tras publicar la carta formal
de pedido el embajador Pablo Monroy me
reporta desde Lima que pudo
entrevistarse a las 13:20 horas con
Pedro Castillo en el centro
penitenciario lo encontró bien
físicamente y en compañía de su abogado
el presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel
López Obrador pidió garantías para
Castillo Entonces
nosotros pedimos que se le respeten sus
derechos humanos que se actúe
con legalidad verdadera
se protege a su familia más temprano en
Perú la corte ordenó siete días de
detención antes del juicio en su contra
por el presunto delito de rebelión se le
acusa por su intento de disolver El
Congreso cerrar la fiscalía y Llamar a
un gobierno de emergencia con toque de
queda y pedido de elecciones sin apoyo
de sus ministros el ejército las
autoridades judiciales el episodio
terminó con su arresto y la posesión de
sus vicepresidenta Dina boluarte como
nueva dirigente de Perú la primera mujer
en asumir este cargo de momento boluarte
descartó elecciones anticipadas Yo sé
que hay algunas voces que indican
adelanto de elecciones Y eso
democráticamente es respetable creo que
la Asunción de la presidencia en esta
oportunidad es un poco reorientar lo que
hay que hacer con el país más adelante
en coordinación con todas las
organizaciones
estamos viendo alternativas Mientras
tanto en Lima se mantienen algunas
manifestaciones de partidarios de Pedro
Castillo que piden su Liberación y
acusan a la nueva presidenta de traición
pasamos a Estados Unidos la cámara de
representantes aprobó el proyecto de ley
que protege a nivel Federal los
matrimonios interraciales y los de las
personas del mismo sexo una norma que ya
había sido avalada en el senado esto
significa que ya sólo falta la firma del
presidente Joe biden para que dichas
uniones sean reconocidas en todos los
estados incluso En aquellos donde no son
legales los matrimonios igualitarios o
interraciales veamos el informe
un paso importante para reforzar el
matrimonio igualitario en Estados Unidos
la cámara de representantes aprobó un
proyecto de ley que protege estas
uniones a nivel Federal un debate
acalorado se vivió en la sala Este es
otro paso más hacia la meta de los
demócratas de desmantelar la familia
tradicional silenciar las voces de la fe
y deshacer permanentemente el cimiento
de nuestro país tejido por Dios sería
incorrecto decir que mi esposo fill y yo
tenemos un matrimonio que es diferente
al matrimonio de cualquier otra persona
aquí en este cuerpo el seguro de salud
de mi centro de trabajo debe extenderse
a mi esposo al igual que el suyo se
extiende a su cónyuge la aprobación fue
aplastante así lo dio a conocer Nancy
pelosi en uno de sus últimos actos como
presidenta de la cámara
en esta votación los sí son 258 los no
son 169 se adopta la moción
la medida surgió de las preocupaciones
que generan un posible revés de la Corte
Suprema a este tipo de uniones como
ocurrió con la legislación que permitía
la interrupción del embarazo el proyecto
promueve que el Gobierno Federal
reconozca el matrimonio entre dos
personas del mismo sexo si es legal en
el estado donde se casaron y además se
reconoce la libertad religiosa tras la
aprobación el presidente Joe biden no
tardó en reaccionar en este día Jill y
yo estamos pensando en las parejas
valientes y los defensores
apasionadamente comprometidos que han
luchado durante décadas para garantizar
la igualdad en el matrimonio en todo el
país ante la Corte Suprema y en el
congreso si bien estamos un paso más
cerca de nuestro largo viaje para
construir una Unión más perfecta nunca
debemos dejar de luchar por la igualdad
total para los estadounidenses lgtbiq+ y
todos nuestros ciudadanos la ley fue
ratificada por el senado el mes pasado
ahora deberá ir al despacho oval para su
aprobación final por parte del
presidente Joe biden para que entre en
vigor
Avanza en Canadá la cop 15 la
conferencia sobre la biodiversidad que
comenzó el 7 de diciembre en Monreal
esta vez la Cumbre tiene un propósito
particular y es crear un nuevo marco
para proteger la diversidad biológica
del mundo en medio de esta gran Apuesta
La Unión Europea acordó el martes
prohibir la importación de productos
agrícolas que vengan de plantaciones
donde hubo deforestación así a partir
del primero de enero de 2023 las
compañías que exporten al gluco al
bloque productos como café soya o
derivados de las reses deben demostrar
que no están relacionados con la
deforestación algunos líderes indígenas
hablan de hipocresía Porque mientras el
bloque se traza esas metas aseguran que
no los protege lo suficiente
en una ventana de no solo a profundizar
nuestra voces y no poder dialogar con
ustedes y con toda la sociedad
del planeta Entonces es lamentable
parece que fuera una doble discurso una
doble moral de nuestros líderes
mundiales que están al frente
precisamente proteger la humanidad y de
proteger los recursos naturales y
también en la cop 15 las organizaciones
independientes intentan presionar para
lograr este nuevo acuerdo que proteja a
la biodiversidad y que sea lo más
ambicioso posible nuestra enviada
especial a la Carolina Villa mediana
conversó con Lucía Ruiz coordinadora de
biodiversidad de WWF México Esto fue lo
que nos dijo
para el 19 de diciembre Esperamos que
temas como financiamiento sostenible el
marco de implementación
temas de Cómo reducir la huella de
consumo y de producción una meta para
conservar el 30% de la superficie global
pero también con un enfoque de
inclusividad y participación se pueda
cumplir y pasamos a hablar del mundial
de fútbol en Qatar porque este viernes
comienzan los cuartos de final y los
protagonistas son nada más y nada menos
que dos latinoamericanos primero Brasil
jugará contra Croacia y luego argentina
se enfrentará a Países Bajos sin embargo
varios de los jugadores de estas
elecciones están en duda nuestro enviado
especial adoja Juan pupiales nos cuenta
que podría pasar en la jornada del
viernes
después de dos días sin fútbol aquí en
Qatar regresa a la actividad en la copa
mundo de Qatar 2022 se abren los cuartos
de final por un lado esta jornada la
abren el Duelo entre Brasil y Croacia y
en el segundo turno Llegará el momento
para Argentina que se mide a Países
Bajos comenzando con la canarinha y la
verdeamarela tiene la duda de si
finalmente alexandro podría ser
inicialista para jugar por el lateral
izquierdo por esa misma banda las dudas
también están En Croacia sobre si
finalmente borna Sosa estará apto para
disputar este partido con el combinado
europeo por el lado de Argentina las
dudas son sobre si finalmente Rodrigo de
Paul uno de los Pilares en la medular
para el director técnico Lionel escaloni
estará apto para este encuentro algo que
el seleccionador no aclaró en la rueda
de prensa previa de este enfrentamiento
con los neerlandeses para los dirigidos
con Luis bangal es una nueva oportunidad
para demostrar que son verdaderamente
aspirantes al título
el propio bancal la copa mundo para
nosotros comienza realmente este viernes
y de Qatar volvemos a América porque los
científicos en Hawai dicen que la lava
del volcán más grande del mundo el mauna
loa ya no es una amenaza inminente para
la carretera principal que cruza la Isla
Grande el monte que entró en erupción el
27 de noviembre luego de 38 años de
quietud aún sigue activo Pero ha
reducido notablemente su magma lo que
devuelve la tranquilidad a la población
así llegamos al final de estas noticias
ustedes sigan con nosotros
[Música]